maritime sise a common
information sharing environment for the
european maritime domain
europe is maritime connected to the
wider world by the oceans that surround
us
seas bristle with activity at all times
and are subject to a wide array of
threats including accidents piracy
illegal fishing crime ecological
disasters and
terrorism these threats are not limited
to coastal states they can rapidly
expand across mainland europe
effective and efficient monitoring is
needed to ensure the environmental
health of europe sees and the safety and
security of its citizens
this is fishing vessel ruler aurora
aurora
mms
in search and rescue operations every
second counts any delay can have fatal
consequences
maritime cc is a voluntary collaborative
process that facilitates and promotes
information sharing leading to enhanced
knowledge
improved cooperation better prevention
and responses
the eu's maritime domain and interests
stretch the world
and by helping the actors involved in
its surveillance increase their
interconnectivity
maritime sise will reduce the threats to
european interests
anywhere at any time and the costs and
efforts involved
a lot is being done in the european
union with several hundred authorities
gathering data sometimes duplicating
efforts across member states and regions
these authorities do communicate but
mainly within single sectors
and countries in an ever-changing global
situation
more cooperation is necessary to reduce
costs
and increase awareness cooperation will
be increased by interlinking
existing information systems enhanced
and automatic information exchange will
be eased by common interoperability
standards
by voluntarily sharing information and
taking the best from all actors
assets and existing information systems
sise will help today's surveillance
authorities plan
and react for a better tomorrow